JASON CHAFFETZ JOINS US.
HERE'S WHAT I HEARD, ANOTHER
BEAT DOWN, A DISASTROUS STATE
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
ARE WE EVER GOING TO GET THE
TRANSCRIPTS SO WE CAN SHOW AGAIN
TODAY, THE BOSS LITERALLY SAYING
NOTHING WRONG ON THAT CALL,
THERE WAS NO ALTERATION OF THE
TRANSCRIPT.
MORE LIES TOLD BY THE LEAKING
DEMOCRATS.
JIM JORDAN.
>> I DO THINK WE WILL GET THE
TRANSCRIPT SOMETIME, IT'S UP TO
ADAM SCHIFF AND NANCY PELOSI,
THEY'RE MAKING THE RULES UP AS
THEY GO ALONG, THEY ARE TRYING
TO PASS THIS REVOLUTION
TO PASS THIS RESOLUTION BUT THAT
DOESN'T CHANGE IT.
IT'S STILL A SHAM PROCESS.
HOPEFULLY WE LOOK AT THE
TRANSCRIPTS AT SOME POINT THEY
SAID THEY WERE GOING TO HAVE
PUBLIC HEARINGS BUT LOOK, WHEN
YOU DO THIS IN SECRET IN THE
BUNKER IN THE BASEMENT OF THE
CAPITAL WHERE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN'T SEE IT, I THINK
THEY UNDERSTAND THIS IS A FLAWED
PROCESS AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
GET IT.
IT'S UNFAIR AND PARTISAN AND I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
STAND FOR IT.
OUR PARTY STAYED TOGETHER AND WE
ALL VOTED AGAINST THIS WHICH WAS
A GREAT SIGN IN THE GREAT
MESSAGE TO THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: IT'S OBVIOUS, WE KNOW
WHAT NEWT GINGRICH DID IN TERMS
OF BILL CLINTON,
JASON CHAFFETZ -- I'VE GONE OVER
IT MANY TIMES ON THIS PROGRAM.
EVERY CONSIDERATION, EVERY DUE
PROCESS, THE RIGHT TO CALL
WITNESSES, CROSS-EXAMINE
WITNESSES, DENY EVIDENCE BEING
ADMITTED, ADMIT EVIDENCE -- ALL
OF THAT WAS ALIVE.
NONE OF THIS WAS A LIE, YOU MUST
BOW AT THE FEET OF THE
CONGENITAL CORRUPT COMPROMISED
LIAR AND BEG PLEASE MAY WE HAVE
PERMISSION SIR AND BEG FOR
ANYTHING AND HE GETS TO SAY NO.
>> WHAT NANCY PELOSI AND
ADAM SCHIFF DID WAS TRY TO SELL
THIS SHAM TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BY SAYING THERE'S A FORMALIZED
PROCESS AND ITS MORE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT.
LITERALLY TODAY, THE EXACT DAY
THEY VOTED ON THIS, THEY WERE
HAVING TRANSCRIBED INTERVIEWS IN
THE DARK AND TOMORROW THEY ARE
GOING BACK TO THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, IS THAT GOING TO BE
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT, IS THAT
GOING TO BE OUT ON TELEVISION
WITH REPORTERS AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS BEING ABLE TO LOOK
AT IT?
YOU HAVE ELECTED MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS CANNOT GO INTO A
HEARING WHICH IS AN UNCLASSIFIED
HEARING AND THAT IS WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN EVEN AFTER THIS
THING PASSED.
IT IS A TOTAL SHAM THAT EMPOWERS
ADAM SCHIFF MORE, IT HAS BECOME
MORE SECRETIVE NO MATTER WHAT
THE SPEAKER SAYS.
>> Sean: HERE'S WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND, JIM JORDAN IF HE IS
A FACT WITNESS WHICH HE IS, GO
WITH OTHER THINGS THAT WE KNOW.
THERE IS CONTACT WITH THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER, HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER, DON'T WE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT THE
CONTACT WAS?
DON'T WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COLLUDED?
TO WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
THE RELATIONSHIP IS WITH
JOHN BRENNAN, THE BIGGEST TRUMP
HATER, MOST CORRUPT INDIVIDUAL I
THINK WE'RE GOING GOING TO LEARN
A LOT ABOUT IN THE DURUM
INVESTIGATION?
DON'T WE HAVE A RIGHT TO FIND
OUT THOSE FACTS?
>> REMEMBER THIS, FIVE WEEKS AGO
ADAM SCHIFF SAYS WE NEED TO HEAR
FROM THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, TODAY
HE SAYS WE DON'T NEED TO HEAR
FROM THE WHISTLE-BLOWER -- WHAT
CHANGED IN THAT FIVE WEEK TIME
FRAME?
ONE FUNDAMENTAL FACT, WE LEARNED
THAT ADAM SCHIFF'S STAFF HAD MET
WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
NOW HE SAID WE DON'T REALLY NEED
TO TALK TO THIS GUY.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE ADAM SCHIFF
UNDER OATH IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ASK THEM
QUESTIONS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
HE IS THE ONLY GUY IN AMERICA
WHO KNOWS THIS INDIVIDUAL IS WHO
STARTED THIS WHOLE THING.
IN THE COMPLAINT, THE BULLET
POINT NUMBER ONE TREND, THE SAYS
"OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS I'VE
TALKED TO MORE THAN HALF A DOZEN
U.S. OFFICIALS WHO FORM THE
BASIS OF THIS COMPLAINT" WHO ARE
THERE WAS MORE THAN HALF DOZEN
U.S. OFFICIALS?
I WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO THEM AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE
PEOPLE WHO GAVE THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER THE INFORMATION
AND JUDGE THEIR CREDIBILITY
UNDER OATH IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE, NOT IN SECRET IN THE
BASEMENT OF THE CAPITAL BUT IN
AN OPEN HEARING WHERE WE CAN ASK
THEM QUESTIONS AND THEY HAVE TO
ANSWER THEM UNDER OATH AND WE
SEE HOW THEY RESPOND.
THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD WORK FOR
THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S GOING TO
WORK BECAUSE THIS PROCESS AS
JASON JUST SAID IS A SHAM.
>> Sean: NOT ONLY WAS THE
PRESIDENT EXONERATED BY THE
TRANSCRIPT BUT WE SEE THE
PRESIDENT FOR THREE YEARS -- WE
HAVE HEARD ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE
OUTSIDE ELECTION INTERFERENCE OF
FOREIGN COUNTRIES IS.
THE PRESIDENT SANG TO THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE WHO WE KNOW
FROM A UKRAINIAN COURT THAT THEY
COLLUDED WITH HILLARY CLINTON,
THE POLITICAL RIGHTS ABOUT A DNC
OPERATIVE MEETING IN THE
UKRAINIAN EMBASSY IN D.C. TO GET
DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP TO HAVE
UKRAINE COLLUDED IMPACT THE 2016
ELECTION IN HER FAVOR -- I GUESS
DONALD TRUMP IS DOING HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY, FAITHFULLY
EXECUTING LAWS -- HEY, GIVE US
ANY EVIDENCE YOU HAVE AND IN
SPITE OF WHAT THE MEDIA SAYS,
THERE IS A QUID PRO QUO.
CRAZY UNCLE JOE, YOU FIRE HIM,
GET A BILLION DOLLARS.
YOU DON'T FIRE HIM, YOU DON'T
GET A BILLION DOLLARS, YOU HAVE
TO FIRE THE GUY WHO'S PAYING MY
SON MILLIONS WHO HAS NO
EXPERIENCE WITH UKRAINE OR
ENERGY WHATSOEVER.
I THINK THAT SOUNDS LIKE
CORRUPTION TO ME.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE HE WAS BUYING
FAVOR, MAYBE I'M JUST MAKING
THAT UP.
MAYBE THAT'S A CONSPIRACY THEORY
MAYBE THAT'S A CONSPIRACY THEOR
THEORY.
>> THIS A LOT OF US THAT
BELIEVED THE RUSH TO THIS VOTE
HAPPENED WHEN IT DID IS THEY
KNOW THE HOROWITZ REPORT IS
MOMENTS AWAY AND THEY WANTED TO
GET OUT IN FRONT OF IT SO THEY
CAN CONCOCT THIS NEW SPIEL NEXT
WEEK TO SAY THAT'S JUST
DONALD TRUMP.
HIS CONDUCT IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO COVER UP THE
IMPEACHMENT -- THAT IS SUCH A
LIE BUT HOROWITZ IS GOING TO
COME OUT, HE'S GOING TO COME UP
WITH THE TRUTH AND IT IS GOING
TO BE UGLY, UGLY, UGLY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Sean: THEY ARE UPSET ABOUT
THAT.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN ASKING FOR OUR
TIMELINE, WE WILL PLAY YOU THAT.
ALSO LARA TRUMP, THE ONLY THING
I CAN TELL YOU IS I TALKED TO
MARK LEVIN TONIGHT, HE IS FIRED
UP AND HE'S COMING UP STRAIGHT
AHEAD.